an fbi agent accused of suppressing the
hunter biden laptop investigation among
other acts of political bias
was escorted out of the bureau building
resigned and there's conflicting reports
as to whether or not this was just a
resignation and escorting someone out is
totally normal or
this is something more serious and i
think despite the reporting of the
contrary it is more serious because this
individual was placed on leave and the
resignation was probably one of those
things where they're like i demand your
resignation over this and then the guy
resigns so maybe this is good news we'll
talk about that because the greater
context donald trump is livid calling
out this fbi agent saying he was fired
joe biden is now coming out saying the
attacks on the fbi are are egregious but
i just got to tell you man more and more
we look at it the fbi looks completely
corrupt and it's actually pretty scary
so we'll get into all that we got a
bunch of other stories we have taiwan
firing warning shots at a chinese drone
this is creepy because we also have
conflicting reports cnn says
unidentified drug we don't know and nbc
says it was a chinese drone so who's cnn
covering for and then we got this crazy
story out of portland these these people
took over the city for street racing
whatever many of them are antifa leftist
types leftist types who want lawlessness
and they started shooting at some old
guy and then killed one of their own
this is what's happening on the streets
in this country so we'll get into all
that and much much more before we get
started my friends head over to
timcast.com become a member we're gonna
have a member's only show coming up for
you at 11 p.m so check that out we've
got we've got the latest episode of the
cast castle vlog is up members only and
this one is called mtg slayer starring
marjorie taylor green so i think you'll
get a kick out of it's good fun and
again that's the cast castle vlog and
then also click the link in the
description below if you'd like to
purchase our latest song only ever
wanted it is the first song that we
released officially under tim cast
records i guess it's we're calling it
and we're gonna be releasing a lot more
music and uh producing a lot more with
your support we might actually get this
song to chart we have until thursday so
click the link in description below buy
it 69 cents if you want to support us
joining us smash the like button
subscribe to channel share the show with
your friends joining us today to talk
about the fbi donald trump corruption is
peter navarro
tim really good to be back with you here
sir and uh
the rural maryland uh it's just a sweet
little spot out here and you got the
music going on during the day and uh oh
yeah
this good stuff at night can you uh you
want to introduce yourself what you did
who you are
uh sure i
am uh one of only three
senior white house advisors who served
with
president trump in the white house
starting all the way from the campaign
in 2016 uh to what we like to uh
joyfully call the end of his first term
just to
make it clear that he's still very much
uh in the game my bag as it were
was dead center
deplorable make america great again
trump republicanism my
remit
for the first three years of the trump
white house tim was
to
create blue-collar manufacturing
jobs um in america and in order to do
that
we had to do a combination of things one
we had to level the playing field
internationally with the trade cheaters
which at the top of that list was of
course communist china so i was
known as uh along with uh brother steve
bannon before he uh exited the white
house as the the china hawks
um and then the uh the second way to go
about bringing manufacturing home was to
prosecute aggressively the buy america
hire america policies
of the administration so i was um
i mean one of the
one of the triumphs i think of the trump
administration
um was to
first of all get tough on china but
second of all to bring in
the old reagan democrats the trump
democrats that became republicans
because
we really focused like a laser
on
good jobs at good wages for the people
so it was a
it was an interesting four years but
part of the reason i'm here i got a this
new book out called taking back trump's
america
the mission of that book
is to win back
uh the house of representatives in 2022
in november
we'll talk more about that later i'm
sure
but also put trump back in the white
house in 2024 but
really the importance of the book
is
to talk about the difference between
trump republicanism and and rhinos the
republican name only so that's why
biden is uh drawing distinction between
right now saying the maga republicans
semi-fascism and all that stuff so we'll
get into all that you were also uh
they also arrested you i believe right
uh yeah i guess i buried the lead there
yeah right yeah yeah
since you were
leg irons baby they put you in leg irons
they put they put me in leg irons
uh the the bigger story here let me let
me give context well i i don't want to i
don't want to get into it before yeah
okay so they put me in leg irons and and
solitary confinement denied me an
attorney
kept me in solitary confinement in a
dungeon
they seem to be happy about the fact
that i was in the same cell
that uh john hinckley sat in after he
shot reagan this seems to be kind of
something that stuck in their minds it's
like the guy who created hundreds of
thousands of manufacturing jobs in the
white house and during the pandemic
saved hundreds of thousands of lives was
sitting in the same cell as the guy who
shot ronald reagan okay
that's that's the fbi folks as we know
it we'll go off we'll get in a little
bit later yes sir so thanks for joining
us we also have hannah claire brimello
hi i'm hankler brumlo i'm a writer for
timcast.com very easy yeah sure dudes
ian crossland here man peter i'm glad
you're talking about industrialization
my brother ian good to see you again so
i don't know if you're familiar but we
can um retrieve carbon dioxide from the
atmosphere and deposit it okay graphene
bearing
how about how about we get into the show
already
this show is hot i'll tell you about it
so it's a way i think that we can bridge
the gap between environmentalists and
national industrialists you know it's
funny you say that if if i may here it's
like
my background by the way and don't hold
this against me you have a phd in
economics from harvard so it's like this
is kind of this it's like this is my
wheelhouse and the idea
that that we could ever solve
the issue of carbon dioxide emissions
on the demand side is ludicrous because
no matter how much you would ever
restrict
carbon
consumption here
in the united states and in europe
whatever we did would be far outstripped
by growth of that
in india and particularly china i mean
so it's it's freaking absurd it's
friggin absurd and i i've but but to his
point if just carbon capture on the
supply side if you're going to do this
that's what we should focus on you do
with methane and carbon dioxide yeah
we'll get
i'm very excited for this show we're
gonna have a great time in case you guys
didn't already notice let's jump into it
actually no no no no we're getting
dragged up we're getting uh jammed up
again i just want to give a shout out uh
we could pull this up to tom mcdonald
who's currently number three on the rap
and hip hops itunes because i was saying
the other day like if you don't want to
support our music tom mcdonald's got
better stuff than than we do and if
everybody just bought his stuff the
point is just to to to take over the
culture to to create more culture and
he's certainly doing it so he tweeted
out that he's currently number three on
itunes because i was shouting him out so
you guys rock and chat mcdonald and he
was like fake woke like a really old
song all of a sudden it's popping up on
the charts because tim's shouting it out
yeah but yeah man it's about
affecting culture man let's jump into
this first story finally
here we go from the post millennial fbi
agent accused of suppressing hunter
biden laptop investigation resigns
escorted out of building now this story
is really interesting because there's
conflicting reports as to whether or not
he just resigned or he was forced to
resign
and this the story from the washington
times is that this guy tim tubal retired
over the weekend but was previously on
leave for about a month
according to the washington times to
bought retired of the weekend on friday
eyewitness accounts state he was seen
exiting the washington bureau's elevator
while being escorted by two or three
headquarters looking types tabal was
named by senate judiciary ranking member
chuck grassley in july in a july letter
to fbi director ray and attorney general
mayor garland that cited whistleblowers
who alleged political bias from
high-ranking officials according to
grassley the whistleblower said the fbi
and justice department employees must
follow strict guidelines to open an
investigation into balt did not follow
them he said as you are aware assistant
special agent in charge tim tubal i'm
probably pronouncing it right is not al
is is not the only politically biased
fbi agent at the white at the washington
field office adding the fbi answers to
congress and the american people
tubal was one of 13 special agents in
charge of the at the washington field
office and had been under fire from
republicans in congress after it was
revealed that he made anti-trump post on
social media in the lead-up to the 2020
election while he was supposed to be
helping to direct the investigation of
hunter biden
well as we know from these
whistleblowers the fbi blocked that now
donald trump came out and said this is
the guy that was leading the raid on
mar-a-lago
other media outlets have come out said
that's not true but this guy's the
washington field office and it was the
washington field office that was in
charge of this so
all of the news coming out is
conflicting fox news said it's it's
unceremonious that he was escorted out
that's normal and that it was just a
resignation while the washington times
saying he says he's being forced out
who do you believe now this is the
challenge so peter what's going on is
the fbi a bunch of uh a bunch of good
guys just trying to help help us all
live better lives are they going after
the criminals or are they biden's
personal gestapo yeah let's put this um
in historical context if you go back
to the days of j edgar hoover the fbi
has a has a very
tawdry history
abusing the agency
for political ends martin luther king i
think was the poster child
of the wrath of of god um aka jay edgar
but others many others felt the
investigatory weaponization of that
agency so
that supposedly went away but but i
would argue and tim let's put this this
hunter laptop biden
incident um in in its broader historical
perspective and we start
when i was on the campaign
uh in
2016 with donald trump in
trump tower in manhattan
prior to the 2016 election
the so-called russia hoax
began the russia oaks is a discredited
russia hoax
which was supposed to somehow tie
trump as some kind of puppet of putin
right it's just it's just it was a
democrat
operative
funded by hillary clinton that got it
started but it was the fbi agents like
peter strzok
uh
lisa page comey himself others
and that was where
the first
preemptive coup
was attempted
on donald trump okay what what they
wanted to do prior to the election was
taint him with the russia hoax and
hillary would win that didn't work but
that russia hoax
continued for for several years led by
former fbi director
mueller and
they took they took a lot of prisoners
to him a lot of casualties i mean mike
flynn i love that guy i was with him in
the trump tower
during the transition we had great plans
he was going to be the national security
advisor we were going to crack down on
china would have made a real difference
they got him in an entrapments game they
got george papadopoulos they got paul
manafort they they did an over the top
rate of roger stone with frogmen and
guns blazing leaks to cnn there's a
pattern here that's my point here tim
there's a pattern here preemptive coup
prior to 2016.
a coup they attempted throughout the
years that trump was in
and fast forward to hunter biden laptop
they succeeded in that coup
if you believe
two things one mark zuckerberg says the
fbi told them to suppress any
information about the hunter biden
laptop prior to the election and the fbi
had that thing for over a year they knew
the information was accurate that that
guy was was was into pornography crack
and most importantly influence peddling
but but it's not just that it's that
there's connections between him and his
dad and their business dealings which is
i think more than just being a bad
person according to mark the fbi game a
general
warning like hey watch out for
misinformation and then mark took it
upon himself to censor the accept biden
thing except whistleblowers came out and
said
that they knew the hunter hunter binding
laptop thing was happening and they
should not investigate it because they
didn't want to interfere in the election
at the same time went to mark zuckerberg
and said hey we want to actually put our
thumb on the scale so watch out for the
information we deem to be misinformation
you can't play it both ways you can and
and interestingly enough last week i had
to i had to step in as a guest host for
brother bannon on his show and when that
story broke that day i interviewed
miranda devine why is that important she
wrote the book laptop from hell
the new york post was sort of broke the
story and twitter took them off and
facebook and what she said was
zuckerberg flat out lied because
um
he and facebook were much more
aggressive than twitter but here's what
we had actually someone message us in
the super chats last night yeah saying
zuckerberg lied they had they had been
permanently banned from facebook over
sharing 100 laptop story during the
election yeah he he he made twitter
sound like they were the like the tough
guys and they saw no bs calling bs on
mark but but the main thread here
is
the fbi
i i see them as as an insurrectionist
okay think about this and if you look at
webster's dictionary and insurrectionist
is is armed people who are trying to
overthrow the quote constituted
authority okay trump was president for
four years armed fbi agents in the
executive suites and down
tried to overthrow trump and they
succeeded well now they succeeded the
the polls here tim you know what the
polls say about hunter biden laptop
right
from rescues and i think it found what
seven percent of people would have voted
for trump had they known about this yes
so trump should be in the white house
but but what do you what do you think
about the fbi going after hillary
clinton's emails because the argument
that the left makes is that well if
comey hadn't done the investigation over
her emails she would have gotten the
same bump and she would have won well uh
in the dual system of justice i'm the
guy in leg irons
trump's the guy who has has a uh a raid
on mar-a-lago despite cooperating with
the national archives of that's
incredible bangs
and eric holder who was the attorney
general under obama who killed people
with his his mis
operation down in mexico with with gun
running
he was charged they were wrecked they
recommended the same charge for him as
me he went free hillary's free peter
strzok's on cnn making six or seven
figures and that was the sob at the fbi
in the top executive suites
who was directly responsible for
manipulating information to perpetuate
the russia hoax and so so to finish the
thought it's like now we have another
preemptive coup we had one in 2016 that
failed we had an actual coup by the fbi
that succeeded because they suppressed
the hunter buying information which
would have swung the election to trump
and now we have another attempted
preemptive coup at mar-a-lago trying to
stick him with a criminal charge that
would prevent him from running so the
question here is
to this news point is this one guy
how many bad apples are in that bunch
and i go back 13. i
a thousand two i mean how many i go back
to why
i'm here in a little way i think taking
back trump's america books mission is to
get control of the house of
representatives in november so that we
can start issuing the subpoenas to the
fbi the department of justice the
national archives and find out just what
exactly is going on who's calling these
shots who who decided to go down to
mar-a-lago
when the guy's cooperating with him and
and go down there with armed agents what
a steal boxes what did cash patel say
what did cash patel say he thinks
that the boxes they took are related to
some of the cover-ups inside the fbi
related the russians so this is
plausible the affidavit
said that they were covered 15 boxes
uh i think they they they they seized 11
doc uh packets of documents or something
like that great for my wrong correct me
if i'm wrong hannah clear uh
it said that donald trump was instructed
that he had boxes that may contain
classified information by the national
archives so he then sent those boxes oh
yeah here you go take them the national
archives took them went through them and
found newspaper clippings
personal memos from the president and
some classified information spattered
among these boxes
then sent a message to the fbi saying
hey look what trump had the fbi said
sounds like he's got more probably okay
got a warrant on those grounds and the
warrant said from the first day to the
last day of his presidency and then they
went in search to the house took more
documents so cash thinks the documents
they took were related to russiagate
yeah and that i mean this is a crazy
this is a crazy movie-esque story if
this is really how it played out that
donald trump leaves the white house
declassifying as he goes the crossfire
hurricane documents showing the fbi was
engaged in malfeasance to try and
subvert this country or something like
that
and then while for whatever reason
trump's holding on to these documents
not publishing them
they realize he's got them and they need
an excuse to go in and take them which
is why they needed a broad search
warrant that said from day one to the
last day which is insane the fourth
amendment my understanding prescribes
you need a narrow set for your search
warrant you need to be looking for
something specifically that's approved
of not to simply go to a judge and be
like we think he's got classified
documents good enough for me you can
take anything he has from any point in
his presidency that's insane
the um
that that theory may well be true but
what i did was i went and looked at the
statutes authorizing the the search
and
interestingly enough there's a little
clause right there in the statute says
that if you
hav if you were found to contain
confidential documents
you can't run for office
right think about that it's right there
in the statute so it's like this could
be
russiagate and i believe that well but
it also could be as simple as they
picked those statutes as a way of
stopping trump from waiting
maybe but
i don't think these people are as
powerful as a lot of people think they
are i think obviously we have this unit
of fbi agents and probably many many
more that are really bad
but this won't stop trump that's that's
that's uh um
it's just it doesn't make sense trump is
the president he has broad
declassification powers if not
unilaterally classification powers they
try and compare him to hillary clinton
but hillary clinton was not the
president she doesn't determine what is
classified trump does as the president
so kash patel said this i think back in
january anything trump has is
declassified because he was the
president
look it's two things can be true here
well one is that they can have the
powers that they think they have these
are very powerful people okay they put
people in prison i mean look think about
my situation here tim take a guess okay
how much on lawyers have i already
shelled out for what is a misdemeanor
okay think about that well let's let's
let's start in the beginning 600
thousand so let's let's start from the
making close it's it's over 400 and
that's just the beginning let's start
from the beginning yeah you you got
arrested what happened so
the the overlay here is the january 6th
so-called select committee
which um is selected basically of a
bunch of democrats and two rhino
republicans it's a committee which nancy
call pelosi yourself called
unprecedented because it's a totally
partisan committee which i repeatedly
called long before i ever got a subpoena
a witch hunt in a kangaroo court
designed to build a criminal case
against trump which you can't do okay
you know they put me in that stuff right
yeah they showed a clip of me reading a
news article oh interesting and then
claimed that i was a trump supporter
calling for people to go
never never did they lied jamie raskin
is a liar and an awful person yes
anyway i uh so they they um
subpoena me
uh and command me that's the term they
use to come and testify
before congress and provide them with
some documents now here's the
constitutional problem and the rock and
hard place i'm in as soon as they did
that
we have the fact that trump
invokes what's called executive
privilege okay executive privilege it
goes back to george washington it's a
doctrine
it it it might you know the word
privilege has kind of got a bad rep
these days but the whole idea is for a
president to make effective decisions he
has to be able to have confidential
discussions with his closest advisors
that can't be revealed in the ordinary
course of business so since he evoked in
privilege number one it was not my
privilege to wave number two so i told
the committee repeatedly time and time
again
go negotiate a waiver of the privilege
with the president and his attorneys
this is the same uh argument that's
bannon's legal team uh used right that
he that trump had invoked executive
privilege and he was not same argument
did mark meadows the former chief of
staff
they're arguing you lose the president
loses executive privilege the moment he
walks out of office which is a fanciful
and absurd notion which has no basis in
the law
the point here it would mean that you
have no privilege during the presidency
either it's it's ridiculous it's
privileged it's crazy not to the
individual it's great well
uh
be careful with that because that's kind
of their argument in some sense the the
the just go back to the logic of this it
makes no sense if president trump
understands
trump has executive privilege and and
his predecessor comes in and immediately
strips him over and then he never had it
yeah but i don't think you should be
able to strip the presidency of its
privilege it's just that's okay well so
so it's not the office it's the
individual who held who held the office
like any president who goes in and says
i this privilege is required for the
the reason of having independent
branches if you left and then that could
be taken away from you you'd have civil
war every every four years literally
less less tangent can can a new
president
uh get the information from the old
president's privilege or are they
privileged from each other like they're
not allowed to know what each other has
done when a when a a president pastor
president invokes executive privilege
then that privilege applies to what
whatever it is he's invoked it on and
it's not
the
authority of his advisors who were
considered the top advisor we're
considered alter egos of the president
in other words when they subpoena me
it's like subpoenaing the president so
my point here in terms of my situation
is
trump invokes privilege not my privilege
to wave the committee does nothing to
resolve that issue and the next thing we
know
they
pass a resolution
to hold both vance gavino and myself in
contempt for for failing to comply with
the subpoena
and
okay
hi jinx ensue now the the funny part of
the story and it's the darkly comic uh
in a brutal
uh authoritarian way is i live literally
a field goal kick away from the fbi i
mean i i was a field goal kicker in high
school i could hit the fbi
with a from my
from my balcony in the building i'm in
with a field goal that's how close they
are yet what's what's a good field goal
though how many yards were talking like
40 40 yards 40 yeah yeah i mean it's
just it's just right there right
and so
um
rather than
it
what they should have done with me
is
call
my attorney and arrange what they call a
voluntary arrest this is a misdemeanor
right just hey we've got a restroom for
it come on down we'll do the paperwork
and you know you'll be out out with it
with no bail and you know we'll we'll
deal with this in the courts that's how
it should have went and two days before
they took me i actually talked to the
fbi agent
and said hey whatever you need i'm happy
to cooperate with you guys and that same
day i'd sent a letter to the
uh the attorney uh the you know at the
justice department saying hey i'm
looking for a modus vivendi here call
call this attorney here i'm stuck
between this rock and hard play so it's
like peace right peace
peace brother right peace you know why
and so
on on that friday uh they they let me
leave my home across the street from
them
go to reagan airport sit for an hour in
the boarding area getting ready to go
board a plane to nashville to do mike
huckabee show
and i go through i do my gate ticket
thing and then walk into the jet way and
the next thing i know there's three
armed agents behind me and two armed
agents coming at me right
and
it's like
they take my phone can't call an
attorney put me in handcuffs
take me down the jet way and meanwhile
as soon as that's happening it was like
all the newspapers
had been leaked you know all the media
had this leaked but they kept me in
solitary right
and i go i get fingerprinted i go and
get leg irons strip searched
and you know the
one of the common things is like they're
walking me down and this this guy young
guy i got no problem with
with the people who work at the place
you're just doing their job unlike the
fbi which seems to enjoy doing that job
too much um yeah this guy's walking i'm
supposed to be following and i'm in leg
irons do you ever try to walk in like
cards it's it's not easy right and then
they'd walk me down to the cell they
take away my tie because they think i'm
going to hang myself and my belt because
they think i'm going to hang myself
and um
it's
it's just like
why'd they put you in leg irons
so we can't escape
you know i think they wanted these well
it's bullying coercion look tim look
well i mean you're you're a master
sprinter yeah you rival you're saying
field goal kicker in high school
doesn't understand but this guy man is
pure athleticism but they wanted the
optics is really what it is they wanted
to show you they want to bully coerce me
and and and try to break me and and look
it's like people are crooked it's like
there's a thing a concept called law
fair that we've been having to deal with
in the trump administration really big
time
it's like even if if i'm never convicted
and put in prison for two years which is
what they want to do it's going to cost
me
well over a million dollars just to
defend myself and i'm a misdemeanor over
a misdemeanor and i'm not you know i'm
not i'm not uh i'm not one of the wall
street guys who was in the trump
administration just you know as a
college professor before i got here it's
like what the hell it's like what's
going on here guys
um so you get the bigger issue though
and i get back look the taking back
trump's america book it's a mission for
me it's also my legal defense one but we
got to get the house back we got to get
the house back in november i don't think
it's bullying i don't i don't think it's
what do you think it is i think they
want they want to send a message
to anybody who would work with trump if
trump wins
we will put you in no i i that's i agree
with that it's like
who look who wants to go into government
service i mean all i ever did was all i
ever did was save lives and create jobs
there nobody ever accused me of doing
anything but that the response
from anyone who would want to work with
trump after seeing what they did to you
should be to proudly assert they want to
work with trump and try 10 times harder
to work with trump in the next
administration make them realize when
they do things like this
people will only become more resolved
and stand up for what they believe in
this is why
the united states doesn't negotiate with
terrorists
i this is this is what i learned doing
all the hostile environment stuff
training with with the overseas
um
like when you're dealing with terrorists
terrorists don't like in many
circumstances to kidnap americans
because amer the united states
government will not negotiate at all
they'll just send special forces or
whatever to go and wipe them out and
rescue the americans or the americans
die and so what ends up happening is
typically at least this is what you know
how it was a while ago things changed
with isis
you could have an american gets
kidnapped in the middle east they go
he's an american leave i don't want to
deal with it but a german guy or a
spanish guy those countries they pay up
instantly so what happens they're more
likely to be kidnapped
so what you need the message you need to
send when they do things like this they
want to scare you
make yourself
stand up
be ten times more resolved and say okay
if you want to play these games we're
going to we're going to try twice as
hard 10 times as hard to stand up for
what we believe in work with trump and
take back america
couldn't agree with you more
there's also just a very practical
matter of taking back the house of
representatives and getting the
investigatory powers in the hands of
republicans who will then
send out the subpoenas
to the fbi to the justice department to
the national archives to the democrats
on capitol hill to the white house
uh i just
tim
it's
this this all stinks to high heaven i
mean this is like this is like banana
republic stuff where
whoever is in power tries to punish and
imprison
whoever was in power before so that they
can't come back i mean it's a it's a
it's a story that's been going on
for for hundreds of years in countries
around the world we just never thought
it could happen here why do you think
it's happening here i mean at one point
you were a democrat right do you think
that the party has fundamentally become
flawed or what evolution has taken
place well if you look at the democrat
party itself
the the democrat party that i associated
with
was blue collar america it was it was
the maga folks who want uh real wages
and decent jobs rising and
it's and
we just the democrat party lost their
way long long long ago i mean
i just want to pause real quick and be
like you know they're the party of
slavery and jim crow and the clan and
all that well there is that too yeah
they've had a lot of problems for a long
time look i think probably all of us
sitting around this table are more more
pragmatic pragmatists
um rather than partisans uh you know i i
wanted when i registered as a republican
i wanted to register as a trump
republican because i know what that
means yeah one of the cool things in the
trump taking back trump's america book
is to is to walk through what i call the
iron triangle of mega right it's like
the rhinos
love tax cuts they love deregulation hey
trump trump republicans are on board
with that fine
fine
strategic energy dominance that too okay
what differentiates
the trump republicans
it's an end endless wars
it's secure borders and at the top of
that triangle or pyramid
it's it's fair trade and a level playing
field so blue collar manufacturing
workers can compete
against the sweatshops of asia and the
subsidies of europe uh and and and
that's what
really
trump republicism
means to me and we you know we we had
look
it's what is it uh bill parcells nfl you
are what your record says your record in
the trump administration strip all the
rhetoric away says that we built the
strongest economy in modern history okay
we have turned the strongest economy in
modern history over to a regime
which and you folks are way too young to
understand this
um is a replay of the worst decade of
the 20th century which is the 1970s in
many ways the 70s
were
they certainly rivaled the great
depression years because just for the
sheer length of time they went on i mean
you can't imagine what it's like to have
mortgage rates at 15
i mean that's like you say you're out of
your mind navarro no you go back in the
70s
and we the misery index of reagan was
you know double 10 in unemployment rate
10 interest rates and you were in the
reagan white house right
no no it never was in i you know i
interestingly enough um
and forgive me if i mention this but i i
i explain
that back uh back in the 80s when i was
getting my phd at harvard i did have a
chance to do that um there was a guy
murray wiedenbaum
who uh was the chairman of economic
advice advisors
and he invited me to be his uh
his speech writer essentially because i
i did like op-eds back then like in the
wall street journal and it caught his
eye
but i decided
that um if i ever left
harvard i'd never get come back and
finish so i think i probably made the
right choice there but i want to jump to
this story from the poster millennial
and i want to talk to you guys about
what uh
what portland is becoming what it is
and i guess why it's important that you
know people get out and vote
not just in the congressional elections
but in your local elections as well
the post millennial reports portland
street mob shoots at elderly driver
accidentally kills one of their own
shocking videos emerged on social media
showing scenes of a deadly and fiery
chaos
at lawless street occupations in
portland
at one of the street racing takeovers on
sunday night near the expo center
attended by hundreds an elderly men in a
van appeared to be caught in the road
before being violently attacked by an
armed mob
video posted on social media shows that
as he desperately attended to reverse
and drive away while being attacked he
backed into a car
this is where things are getting a man
in the crowd then fires at least 18
rounds at the fleeing van a follow-up
video shows the crowd catching up with
the elderly man who had stopped in a
patch of grass he appeared to be in
shock and was bleeding heavily there
were hundreds of people
and cars in the area participating in an
apparent illegal street takeover i want
to show you this account
it says my boy's lifelong friend was
killed last night at the street takeover
there's a candlelight vigil tonight at
8pm at the expo center by please plea by
please help get the word out and please
help get candles donated to the location
at eight if you're able to no bs please
respect the family this individual is
abolish ice abolished pigs burned on the
system they say love your friends be
anti-racist don't f nazis black flags
clearly an antifa individual in portland
when andy was saying is a lot of these
people supporting these takeovers are
antifa their leftists they want the
lawlessness this is what you get
but you know what
for whatever reason the people of
portland keep voting for it
so i don't i don't know if there is a
way
to change the minds of individuals who
like that kind of scenario because that
i wouldn't want to live anywhere near it
but if that's the case i don't see a
mending of this country in terms of the
political divide especially with how the
fbi's been treating people it seems like
an inevitability that there's what a
national divorce a civil war or
something like that or maybe a
revolution if one side doesn't actually
stand up and vote
close to home here just last week
i was
on a jog as it were um on the mall and
went up kind of the
the
left side of the capitol hill walkway
right and and it's it's a beautiful just
scene
there's mothers there with with kids in
the carriages and just people having a
good time the next thing i know
um
a hundred
or more
guys come down
on um these uh motorized skateboards
going 30 40 miles an hour
with their helmets and
antifa-like gear i don't know if they
were
and it's a wonder somebody didn't get
killed and so i got up to the top of the
hill and the reason why i'm telling you
this story
is uh
there's a motorcycle cop up there from
the capitol hill police and i go dude
what the what what's going on here it's
like how do you not do anything about
that isn't that your job
and he tells me that they have orders
directly from pelosi
and bowser not to not to do anything
okay wow that's
that's what's going on
here tim and the other story they like
it they the other story that caught my
eye was just this week in dc 16th street
i think somewhere in northwest
um an nfl
player
okay
who has to look formidable okay nfl
player
got shot by two kids
with guns
15 years old
they were trying to
carja i mean it's like why how does that
happen if if it's not because there's no
law
here in in the district of columbia or
portland or everywhere in between it's i
mean it happens to be these democrat
cities
have these skyrocketing crime rates
because
that's how they roll and and i
that's uh
i got no answers for that do you think
it's a cycle they
no it's not a cycle this is like i think
it's it's i think it's cascading out of
control i mean this is the whole
rudy giuliani thing when when he was uh
first uh coming onto the scene and came
with the james q wilson broken window
theory the idea that that if you
let you know one broken window go
without repair then you'll get a lot of
broken windows no my thought is that in
democratic cities being soft on crime
gets you elected but then you have a
crime problem but you can't suddenly be
tough on crime because then you'll lose
your seat right
i'm trying to find out who who the heck
these people are who were voting for
these people i mean it just it's just
what
portland is a great city it used to be a
great used to be a great city it used to
be i'll tell you how it works what is
going on there tim you may have got a
better handle on this
i mean
people uh people care more about social
conformity than they do about the future
of this country i think that's really
fairly obvious i think one of the
problem with cities and this is an uh i
believe an inevitability i remember when
i got wrongly pulled over in chicago i
couldn't do anything about it what am i
supposed to do cop gave me a ticket and
said ha ha
i wasn't speeding didn't matter he said
tell it to a judge a judge said go screw
myself yeah under 21 my license got
suspended so what happens then is
when you get cops that are using quota
systems or in chicago it's real dark
where they have black sites where
they'll arrest people and bring them
without anyone knowing and beat them
things like that no joke this stuff
happens there was one guy who's
electrocuting people to force
confessions
when you arrest people or give them
tickets
because you need to make money off them
you're criminalizing regular people who
then demand that this stop and they say
we don't want this anymore we want the
police to back off
then you get mayors who had elected and
say okay police back off then crime runs
rampant it's an it's it's a cycle it's
an it's it's a it's a whirlpool of
destruction this is the crazy thing
about these these ghost quota systems
they claim they don't have we know they
do it we know that in many jurisdictions
there are regular people who are like
hey it's the end of the month better
slow down that's a ridiculous notion but
they want to make money they want it
they want to get money from the
citations and then people say i don't
want to have cops out around anymore
when we talk about
how the left wants to abolish police and
they have these principal narratives a
lot of their narratives i think are
insane right we learned from say like i
think was the washington post something
like between 9 and 19 unarmed black men
were shot in like 2019 not thousands
like black lives matter was trying to
claim but i'm talking to my friend who
who lives in a you know in the baltimore
area and they were like i don't care
about any of that i want to get rid of
the cops because they keep pulling us
over on bs charges or bs claims and
giving us tickets and i'm like okay i
have no argument for that like what am i
saying you did that and they are having
continued problems i mean philadelphia
just falls apart
so look
when when people uh
what i hear from like my suburbanite
friends on the police is
i got pulled over for bs reasons and
they gave me a ticket i'm sick of the
cops
and maybe that's fine if you're in like
a low crime well-off suburb but then
when you start electing people who are
like yeah we hate cops too and start
gutting them you get what's going on in
portland you get what's going on in new
york you get rampant violent crime you
get what's going on in dc and baltimore
it's all getting worse and then you know
these people who voted for it do they
leave
they leave and they come to your area
and then say okay it's kind of nice here
then they get mad at the way things are
being run and then they vote and get it
again
well portland portland breaks my heart
and
the i did this dual system of justice
where you observed for over a hundred
days i was in an administration during
this
they were just burning stuff down just
breaking stuff down and then
back to our fbi story i think there's a
thread here
it's like the two things i didn't
mention which are on the fbi as well
it's like
the the whole gretchen whitmer
thing where
um f10 they had
more fbi informants
trying to kidnap gretchen whitner than
they had
a non-fbi informants and and what was
the motivation behind that they you know
when they broke that story tim i know if
you remember but it was in october early
october right before the election yeah
and it was designed basically to tar
trump it was actually the right brush it
was october surprise
and
on the january 6th day we still
don't know just why we had fbi
informants roaming
near the capital some of them on the
grounds that still
goes unexplained but what i do know is
that that violence
that happened was was um
it led to trump's impeachment
so
i mean
something going on here trump should
have uh
sent in the military during the 2020
riots i thought day two that's something
i told tim actually day two of the riots
i was like he's gotta send in the
national guard what's happening why is
he not stopping i think i think for for
the it's the insurrection he was afraid
more than he looked at as a fascist
don't forget who was the uh secretary of
defense at the time
no it was the mark esper mark millie
show and those guys
turned out to be clowns um this their
you know one of the
one of the tragedies of the first trump
term was all of um
the people who didn't belong there in
powerful positions yeah yeah it
it i i was i
there's a part of me that's worried
about people like millie you know
because i view them as deeply corrupt
and insane individuals but i also
thought about i'm like well they're
cowards too so i really have nothing to
worry about they they they can't do
anything here's why you should worry
they're killing their combat readiness
well that's true though to the extent
that you
uh divert your attention and resources
and organizational culture away from
combat readiness
um and the development of the next
generation of defensive weapons to
protect us against russia and china and
i
instead
down all the roads they've gone down
um it's it's a very very damaging thing
i mean the the the military is in in
deep
deep trouble right now morale wise
um combat reading wise readiness-wise
and everything in between and it's
because
of
people
like millie and and feckless
defense secretaries like esper i mean to
me it's like
esper what the hell why did you keep the
national guard far enough away that they
couldn't be quickly deployed when you
damn well knew that there could be
violence that day is it on purpose well
that's that's
that's the working theory trying to gut
the universe
is that pelosi
uh told the capitol hill police to go
lightly open the barricades under duress
if you needed to the fbi put put
agitators in there and millie uh and
esper kept the national guard far enough
away that they couldn't come to the
rescue in time
so that they could blame trump for
whatever happened and you know they
didn't blame trump for whatever happened
and those things happen so
put it all together
yep
yeah you know like
occam's razor the simplest explanation
is usually
the right one and um do you think trump
should have gotten rid of them earlier
do you think he would should have
removed them
there's uh there's an old uh saying in
in
the reagan administration that personnel
is policy right
meaning that if you put the wrong people
in you're gonna get the wrong policies
reflective of your administration the
taking back trump's america book takes
that a step further it's that bad
personnel not only create bad policy but
bad politics and i go in the taking back
trump's american book i go chapter and
verse from the beginning where we the
original sin of that administration was
to get in bed with the rhinos and then
we got like people like tillerson
at state we got mattis
at defense we had gary cohn goldman
sachs guy of all people leading the
economic policy
inside the white house we lose mike
flynn to the russia hoax russiagate
thing and we wind up with the globalist
h.r mcmaster and and which it was just i
mean it's a cabinet of clowns and it's
just
it just really took its toll and at the
back yeah go ahead 529. you remember
that
529 yeah the insurrection 529 no what's
that the insurrection on 529. when the
far left tried storming the white house
and set fire to st john's church ah yes
yeah the 529 insurrection yes yes see
the issue is
there's a subcommittee for that
yeah maybe maybe there should be there
should be
so
donald trump
and uh law enforcement stopped that
insurrection when they set fire to a
guard post
when i think it was what like 70 was it
70 uh federal agents were injured in the
rioting yeah and more i was like
hundreds total
throughout several days to smoke
all well no the issue was that
this is the way things work and the
victim and victim in uh fifth
generational warfare i'll put it that
way
on 529 trump stopped an insurrection so
who cares
on one six no one stopped a
quote-unquote insurrection so it's
endless news and instead of blaming law
enforcement for their failure they blame
the individuals who went there and i'm
not talking about the people who are
actually violent and rioting by all
means you know charge and arrest those
people i'm talking about the people who
walked in confused and the barricades
were up and the doors were open and
didn't see violence and just were let in
by cops taking selfies with people they
get blamed
if donald trump on 529
said to the police and law enforcement
stand down and back off we don't want
anyone getting hurt because we'll get
blamed for it
let those people tear the fences down at
the white house trump would be president
right now the narrative would be the far
left has gone insane they've crossed the
line they burned down buildings but
trump stopped them so there is no
narrative about far-left violence
whenever the far left goes out of
control they they punch people they beat
people the media doesn't cover it the
only time there was ever a really big
national story was when andy no was
brutally beaten in the street and they
had no choice because the photos were
horrific
but you see the right always tries to
stop the left from going out of control
and then if the right ever ever puts one
toe over the line the media screams
screams the top of their lungs
so that's that that's that's that's that
it's that simple and i can only assume
that pelosi and the democrats understand
that
that when you there's a video of a guy
he's watching january 6 happen people
are going in the building and he looks
at the cops he goes stop them why aren't
you doing anything and the cops don't
care
they just stand there
makes you wonder not that i know for
sure but i tell you this there were
barely any cops there when there were
hundreds of thousands of people that
were that were down there in dc
why did they let these people do this
there were some cops there trying to
stop them that i get
but seriously the seat of the federal
government could not stop 800 people
from walking through a building
is america that pathetic
that the federal government had no
ability okay if the federal government
is that weak
that pathetic and that ineffective this
country is already doomed 800 people
showed up and we were helpless to stop
them that's the narrative of the january
6 committee that the federal government
has become feckless weak pathetic and
ineffective so my response is okay if
they can't stop 800 people from walking
through a building and they're carrying
sticks maybe we should strip them all of
their funding because it's a big fat
waste of money and then i don't know
what we do hire private companies to
handle security in and around the
district i guess because they certainly
couldn't stop it
amazing huh yeah well i remember after
529 too everyone was like trump got
shuttled to a bunker he's such a coward
like all the media was against us and
it's like what are you talking about we
said all of congress later like a couple
months later and it made sense right
the narrative was that trump was weak
for going to the bunker which is just
security protocol but then we got all
those sound bites from aoc telling us
how terrified she was and someone banged
on her door she made that through yeah
well i mean someone probably banged on
her door but the whole story not like in
the context that she thinks it was
though yeah
you know aoc lied about what happened on
january 6 she fabricated a story
claiming that i thought i was going to
die because they made it to my office
even though her story happened an hour
before the capital was breached these
people are sick duplicitous i would
argue
it is it is the simpler solution that
elements of the federal government told
law enforcement to back off
as opposed to assuming the federal
government is unable to stop eight
hundred people
that's an issue
two wins and a loss for whoever told the
military to stand down on january's i
mean i've some they were stood down
whether they were ordered to or not i
don't know but they weren't there they
weren't stopping us because they didn't
want the optics of a bunch of military
breaking people's faces getting into
fights opening fire maybe on the crowd
although ashley babbitt was opened fire
upon um
they they also would have an opportunity
then to claim like we were being
attacked we need more funding for
defense which is a big win but the
downside is if they actually betrayed us
and didn't defend our capital that's a
big downs that's a big problem and the
idea is i always this is what i always
see in the memes this is what they have
to do they have to conflate anyone who
opposes the democratic establishment and
the uniparty with trump michael malus
and uh
he's a
and dave smith are great examples of
this
and it's a meme now that if you come out
and say something about biden they
respond by saying oh yeah but trump and
so you can literally be like
you know biden did a bad job here like
yeah well trump did a bad job here and
you can go yeah okay i don't care i
don't like trump and they still will
treat you like you're a trump supporter
hunter biden could have the bodies of
children in his basement but trump's
economy did you see this sam harrison
you know sam harris podcaster yeah he
said hunter biden could have the corpses
of children in his basement and i would
not care nothing on that laptop would
have changed my mind and then he says
nothing there would be worse than trump
university and that's how deranged
deranged these people are that let's say
the worst case scenario that trump
university all that stuff is all true
that trump had a fake university and
defrauded people oh heavens sure would
be bad
but then to ignore the fact that hunter
biden is shown colluding with foreign
interests potentially involving his
father who's the president assuming
sam are saying that's not worse these
people are deranged literally they are
afflicted with something they're out of
their minds
i think it would be would have been
better
if there was nothing about crack nothing
about sex whatsoever at all on the 100
bite and laptop and allowed us just to
focus
on the real pornography which was the
treason to this country i mean if you i
mean i this that thing hit me so close
to home because i spent four years in
the white house trying to get
manufacturing jobs back from china
factories back from china
and hunters going over there leveraging
the power of daddy to get a billion
dollars from the chinese to buy
factories in michigan and ship them back
over there that was the that's the true
obscenity and to your point tim i just
sam here's i don't know who these people
are but i don't the mindset the mindset
is that's the way they think so that's
the way they want everybody else to
think and that's that's how they use the
media they shape they try to shape the
narrative in a way
which conforms with what they want i
think it's the way around i think they
assume that's what other people think
therefore they're saying what they think
they have to say
i think uh it's it's an ends justify the
means
um in the in the taking back trump's
america book there's a whole section
on the media
and the theme about it is daily control
to dominate the news cycle that if
you're in the white house you understand
that that that's your mission every day
in the white house if you're in the
press corps right you want to dominate
the news cycle in a way which makes your
guy look favorable right
and what we fought every day
was a media willing to take
whatever news there was and
misinformationalize it you know they put
it in their blender
right
and there might be like a story in in
neutral times which would be the number
one story there might be the top three
stories and those wouldn't be the ones
that we'd see every day we'd see
only the ones that would be able to
either put biden in a good light or
trump and a bad light or both
and
to me it's just it's just an ends
justify the means departure from any
kind of morality or ethics
uh simply to get and and the funny part
is and it's it's tragic is they got
exactly what they wanted they got joe
biden and he is destroying everything
they don't hold here but they don't
everything we hold dear and i guess they
don't care i mean
can they not hold
social victory above anything else it's
not about a good economy it's not about
having food it's not about healthcare
it's about saying i won the they you're
talking about though or the ones that
aren't hurt by this
no no i'm talking about the regular
voters you think there's so look not
every single person obviously
but when when when
i look to the people i know in my life
who voted for for for joe biden yeah
they
they're they're staring at record gas
prices no remorse no remorse
remember i remember what bill maher are
these people that's what i keep asking
remember what bill maher said yeah if a
recession stops trump bring on a
recession yeah actually calling for pain
and suffering of working-class people
and the best part is right now at the
student debt forgiveness thing seeing
these people on the left be like we need
to get student debt forgiveness it's
about the working class and i'm like bro
college degree holders are not the
working class they're the bourgeoisie
that's what mark's talked about they're
they're the laptop class these people
are the highest income earners in this
country thinking they're the oppressed
minorities it's true though yeah i'll
use that the laptop class well that's
what it is that's what it is that's
exactly right they they think
they're they're deserving of all of this
meanwhile there's a guy who's making
half the salary they get writing
articles about brad pitt's junk and he's
actually doing something for society you
got working-class people who build
things who clean things who fix things
and then you get people who are like
arts degree holders who are like the
government should they have to make my
debts
yeah okay dude it's not the government
though it's it's me they're asking the
tax payers to do it when they conflate
the government is paying for it with the
taxpayers are paying for i get really
annoyed with but i i had an idea i had
an idea i don't think we can can you
continue to function with people who
look i i don't like the idea of people
taking on loans and then being like i'm
not going to pay them back but i also
don't like the idea of how the interest
rates have made it so that somebody
takes out a thirty thousand dollar loan
ends up paying back a hundred grand
that's insane so here's my idea how
about we do this we'll forgive your
loans but you gotta do four hours per
week of community service at your own
discretion signed off on by a non-profit
or a church we we credit you 50 bucks an
hour for that community service and so
long as you're engaged in that once per
week your loans are frozen and can only
go down how does that sound
it sounds good i still want them to be
able to uh
i think they want i want them to be able
to make it easier to declare bankruptcy
on student loans that's a good point too
i think the fact that we tell 18 year
olds the only way to succeed in this
country is to get a degree that's worth
an insane amount of money because we
made it so you have to that's that will
cost you right right thank you
that's not worth much chris carr please
edit me live
return on investment tends to be
negative yeah exactly you're gonna have
to pay an insane amount of money the
only way to do that is to go into debt
the second you're an adult and then
we're gonna continue to charge that
forever and by the way there's no way to
get out of this unlike any other loan
like it's just an insane system why
would you ever think this is a good idea
except for the fact that you can trap
people who are desperate to try and
pursue this idea that college gives you
an opportunity which in this country at
this point it really does not it did
until about 2006 when you could study
online maybe before that i just think
that the bachelor's degree is an
oversaturated market and so now we have
to drive everyone to get their masters
which farther in student debt which you
can't declare bankruptcy on and just
goes on and on it's the opposite it's
the opposite actually what happened is
people who have degrees are too
expensive and don't have real world
experience man i saw this when i was 18
and i kept telling my friends it's a
trap but they didn't believe me now
they're all really angry that they can't
pay off their debt but it's this simple
if if ian comes to me and he's like i
make music and i say okay okay and prove
that you can make music and he goes
here's a piece of paper signed off on by
an expensive institution that says i
learned how to make music what am i
supposed to do with that some homeless
guy could walk up like i make music and
i'll bet prove it to me and it'll go oh
mcdonald's
well he's singing he's a good singer too
that's more valuable to me than your
certified piece of paper yeah i mean the
joke is online that you get your
bachelor's degree and then you apply for
an entry-level job and they're like do
you have five years of professional
experience because it doesn't mean
anything but think about the kind of
person you'd have to be to walk into
that trap trusting and that's
unfortunate that there's a lot of people
who are going this is why i'm like we
need to find a solution to this but i
certainly do not respect the entitlement
of so many of these people i'm i'm not
comfortable with charging taxpayers
money to pay back sally may for people's
loans i do not want to do that again
they did in 2008 obama paid back and
bailed those companies out and i do not
want to bail them out again in the guise
of a loan repayment uh if they want to
negate sallie mae's books and say hey
you you're worth 580 billion less now
and no these people are not giving you
that 10 grand back each that's another
story whether or not a bankruptcy may i
don't know maybe that's not even the
worst thing i'm sure they would say oh
that would destroy the entire economy if
you bankrupted sallie mae we can't allow
that we need to bankrupt you instead i
don't like it what is your thoughts i
mean you're an economist what
what are your thoughts on this
if you're uh if you're going to go to
college these days
you might want to think about stem stem
education science technology
it's it's the key to getting a decent
job um
the the liberal arts you know
okay liberal arts of the liberal arts i
majored in english i'm okay with saying
it's gotta keep waiting
i think
what you wanna do right now
to educate yourself is download a
survival guide learn how to raise
livestock
and some rudimentary you know
engineering because uh even mark ruffalo
in an interview about whether or not
he's gonna be the hulk he was like well
the way things are going hopefully i'm
still around and there's a world that
can [ __ ] you know exist to do this so
even he's kind of thinking maybe this is
all gonna implode and the world's gonna
end i mean the paradigm has shifted with
the with the access to online education
i remember back when i was at university
of california irvine teaching back in
the 90s i was actually one of the first
pioneers of online education back then
and the the the the
people inside the university were
totally again it because it it basically
it just
ups it gave directs access to students
in a cheap way and it threatened the
whole 10-year paradigm and things like
that and so i think today there's a lot
less need
for the kind of four-year college thing
that people do i mean just go because
there's so much you can learn online
uh and be done with that but and i
always felt bad that these people would
take on these huge loans i mean it's in
a lot of ways it's a scam and you know
my professor elites
i mean we had it pretty good right you
know you you kick back and you don't pay
as much attention to teaching as you
should and things like that um i'd see
this among my colleagues
just i mean we're not we didn't do
the academy did has not done its duty
to our young people and we get what we
get yeah it's it's it's you know you
folks i mean i'm talking i'm an old guy
i'm talking to a very young demographic
here
it's a very different world you're
growing up in your back back when i was
your age
uh we had we had the dream you know we
could get get the good job the the
picket fence the house the car and this
that and the other thing
and um
that's that's both not within reach for
a lot of people and really not their
dream anymore which is interesting in
and of itself i went to an antique store
they had an old radio was very very big
it was like three and a half feet tall
yeah two feet wide and the knobs on it
were like tiny and there was a wheel
that would click you know to like you're
spinning through the frequencies or
whatever and the funny thing is i
thought about i'm like
when this thing was sold the guy who
sold it that was all he did he worked
quite literally at a radio store and he
fed a family of four he had two cars
and he went on vacations and all he did
was sell radios to people yeah now
that's crazy huh yeah today both parents
are working full-time and neither can
afford anything yeah
yeah no it's um
and look
the the concern i have as an economist
and as somebody who is concerned about
the prosperity of this country
is whatever our educational system is
today it's simply not delivering
competitive individuals in a global
marketplace i mean it's just not no it's
not it's just not and um
we spend more on education i think than
any country in the world and we we get
less but would you say that our
education is overpriced i mean i think
there are no questions so many things
we really wanted to have everyone
graduate from college i think the only
reason why they do the four-year thing
is because there's a football season or
something like that i mean yeah yeah
because the first two years you spend
doing general credits
there needs to be the total revolution
in education
um and put put the hands of learning in
the hands of people but
uh
well let's
let's let's talk about that so so you
know you're talking about the power of
the internet people's ability to speak
but i'm gonna jump to the story as kind
of a hard segue post millennial reports
truth social banned from google app
store over content moderation a google
sports spokesperson told
said that truth social lacks content
moderation needed to meet google play's
terms of service
according to the hill the spokesperson
said that truth lacks okay so they wrote
that twice
this comes after truth social ceo dev
nunez claimed last week that the android
version of the uh of the platform's app
is ready waiting only on google's
approval on august 19th we notified
truth social of several violations of
standard policies in their current app
submission and reiterated that having
effective systems for moderating user
generated content is a condition of our
terms for any app to go live on google
play
google is reportedly particularly
concerned about violations of its
policies prohibiting content with
physical threats and incitement to
violence so this is a really interesting
story because
it's just the next link in the chain of
censorship and if we're talking about
people's ability to learn because of the
internet yeah they're clearly trying to
stop that you well but
the the the thing i thought you were
going towards is
um if we're going to have a curriculum
on the internet and they can control
what's in that curriculum then that's
just one more
step towards
that uh
globalist woke nirvana they seem to we
wanted dragging this entire country down
so so there is that trap yeah
that was a
that was a tough one um whoever whoever
is going to be the next secretary of the
department of education uh
needs a vision somewhere somewhere along
the line but this bigger issue of the
the social media conglomerates you know
i get back to
the fbi working hand in hand with
twitter
facebook and by the way there's a
there's a there's a there's a
fascinating funny
tragic story in the taking back trump's
america book as to how twitter and
facebook wound up being so aggressive
against
trump in 2020. i don't know if you guys
know this
but
after
uh trump won the election in 2016
brad parscale who was at that point
during the 2016 campaign the social
media director he became the campaign
manager in 2020. he goes on 60 minutes
and in the big reveal
as he's claiming victory for the trump
victory through his manipulation social
media
he reveals that twitter and facebook had
employees inside the trump campaign
actively trying to help the trump
campaign message right and as soon as
that news hit
all hell broke loose
across this country and particularly in
silicon valley and it was at that point
where
the jack dorsey at twitter zuckerberg or
facebook
pichai at google said
not in 2020
and and they just they
it's very clear now in hindsight that
social media
did everything they could
to skew that election in favor abiding
in against trump
and
that's a really powerful thing and now i
mean this is just this is this is this
is part of why
uh i'll i'll just throw it to andrew
breitbart again pilot i'm i think he's
the one who said politics is downstream
from culture
and then you look at
the
social media censorship a large
component of that is
inhibiting the ability of a culture to
form and develop banning alex jones
battling banning milo yiannopoulos and
people like laura loomer because they
were influential because they were
having an impact on culture so they had
to be erased
truth social this is a really good
example
i was saying for a long time that trump
should have gotten off of twitter
launched his own platform or used minds
or gab or something like that and he
didn't do it until recently with the
launch of truth social but this is
actually a good example of probably why
he didn't they just ban the entire app
outright they didn't just ban one person
google said we will ban every single
person all at once
because they want to control what is
allowed to be said and they want to
limit the in the appearance of trump's
influence and culture they don't want
him to be able to influence culture i
would say especially heading into
midterms yep um i i
i'm a big getter fan i call getter the
twitter killer and one of the things
that's been really interesting about
getting on getter it has all the
functionality of twitter with it with a
lot more elegance and live stream
capabilities but what i'll do is i'll
post identical content
on twitter
and on getter and then watch what
happens
and
what you see
is the shadow banning that twitter does
you can have the exactly the same amount
of followers on both platforms and you
get much more social engagement on
getter because of the algorithms that
lay deep inside the twitter
autocracy and you would never
you would never be able to detect that
unless you had
getter
doing the same content yeah i mean it's
really kind of scary right and it's been
interesting a couple of times i've i've
tweeted on on
twitter about like okay about this and
then she would get i guess the twit
sensors are active shadow banning and
for like a little time after that things
got a little better but it's scary
that
that's the way it works and remember tim
it's like when zuckerberg's talking
about how
he
was able to suppress information about
the hunter biden laptop it was like he
was explaining he did it through
algorithms which would suppress
the
information from coming up to the top
layers so they they know how to do this
and they that's like the the evil genius
of these people they they really know
i mean it's this is goebbels
um in the 21st century here they're
really good at what they do that's scary
the way it was explained to me is that
they want to make sure people who
support trump
are still active
because when you censor people it causes
splashes they don't want people to go
together or truth social whatever they
want them to stay where they are
and they're worried that if they make
too big of moves
it will cause a ruckus but they also
want to censor just enough yeah to make
it
to put it uh put it at a disadvantage so
the left wins
so it's basically like you got two
people running a race one person's
pretty fast one person's kind of slow so
what do you do you crack one person in
the foot and then they can't race as
well but they're still there they're
still running but they just can't make
it yeah that's kind of the idea with how
they're handling censorship they don't
mind certain channels that exist so long
as the more influential ones get hobbled
i think that's right too that's right
did you always you use getter as your
alternative platform
um
interesting um getter
i think it launched july
uh over a year ago and
what what you saw was was the
collapse of
traffic twitter twitter stock
which is really if you look at i mean
twitter's in many ways a dying company
it's like for elon musk to go in and buy
it it's like there were people
on my side of the fence who thought that
was a good idea and oh we're going to
liberate twitter but in fact twitter was
dying okay it's like because because
other platforms were coming on that that
really did it its job better without the
censorship
um
so yeah i don't know how that how that
game
will play out but um it's so the other
thing that that that's so embedded now
um
if you go to like a newspaper article in
the mainstream media right and you want
to
do something with it
facebook and twitter facebook and
twitter have the monopoly on that so so
that builds so i mean i think we need to
build
an all
an alternative
information infrastructure
that
we can
use uh freely without censorship but boy
is that a lot of work
yeah we're building that now actually
well we're building a lot of stuff i
think
oh man it's a depressing monumental task
what it feels like right now because i
can't break up facebook break up
facebook you're gonna facebook messenger
facebook prime instagram you're gonna
have all these separate companies
zuckerberg is gonna still own them all
he's still gonna have all the code and
the monopoly is still gonna be there so
i think the only way to do it or at
least the best way to do it is to make
them free their software code you force
them to open up their algorithms so that
other people can not only watch
what they're shadow banning if they're
shadow banning it what they're tweaking
if they're tweaking but that you can
actually take it and spin up your own
version of the website that
interoperates with their site so like if
i'm on facebook i can see people that
have your version of it if i'm on your
version of it i can see people on
facebook but there's like now there's
competition but it becomes less
competition of code more competition of
terms of service so what system has the
best terms of service which one's
screwing you over the least and people
will migrate there i mean one good thing
about the musk thing is with this
lawsuit
is that he may have subpoena power or
deposition power
to get
to the truth about what they actually do
and that'll be
that'll be fascinating whether he buys
the platform or not yes now in this suit
discovery is a possibility yes yes
they're not going to like that no
they're not gonna like that at all
because because they've got stuff to
hide
yeah he's and he's he's subpoenaed jack
dorsey he's a piece of this
whistleblower i mean whistleblower came
out so
even if he doesn't win well actually him
winning means him not buying twitter so
i would hope he loses you know he has to
buy it yeah you want to buy it yeah yeah
absolutely i just assume
see uh
see it as roadkill on the the getter and
true social super high yeah i think elon
musk taking over would be a good thing
though
but uh well let me and the video
because i've had this debate
um with a couple of pro musk folks
here's what bothers me about elon musk
and it's it's it's a death blow
that sob
took all his money
and went over to communist china
and he's building
teslas yep and his
entire future
is dependent on one whim of xi jinping
okay
so he's got to kiss
china's butt every single day of the
week and he does and he does and as long
as he's doing that
that's not good for america and by the
way that's why he's not
as warm to trump okay he he doesn't love
trump because
because trump is the one guy he he wants
to find he's some republican he can he
can embrace that won't shut his tesla
companies down these
china the wealthy elites are hedging
their bets with china that's what
they've been doing yeah they've been
buying money putting property there but
it's all basically saying swearing
fealty to xi jinping yes because at any
moment he could take those factories
first snap his fingers i got to talk to
you about repositioning the united
states as the top industrial power on
earth there's i mentioned at the
beginning of the show that we can
recapture carbon from the atmosphere um
we're gonna start mining the carbon
dioxide out of the air and the methane
out of the air turning it into carbon
dioxide depositing it onto different
metals palladium gold copper or use it
putting it through other chemicals to
turn it into graphene which is pure
carbon hexagonally latticed
like a honeycomb lattice single layer of
carbon pure carbon and it's got it's
conductive like more conductive than
copper it's stronger than steel you can
make touch screen wallpaper out of it
you can make clothing out of it um it's
going to be the 21st century building
material and if we start this mining
operation now in the united states we'll
be able to say hey because what's going
to happen is people are going to start
mining it and they're going to start
mining too much if we're not careful
they'll start competing with the trees
and they'll start killing off the trees
because we've taken all the carbon
dioxide too much out so we need to work
with the globe to figure out how much
carbon we're supposed to be putting out
and taking back
but i think it could be a you know
multi-trillion dollar industry at the
very least i don't think it has to be
about money at this point because it's
really about the sustainability and
survival of our species but i think the
united states is the place to build it
well i don't know we talked we talked
offline before the show about
the insanity of trying to solve uh the
carbon issue on the demand side
because no matter how much we save here
in the u.s china and india is going to
do more but it's not just
go ahead it's not just that yeah
there's a
there's a mathematical equation that
tracks this if you start to uh let's say
we replace energy
consumption we replace our energy
sources with nuclear we start setting up
these nuclear power plants
then you will have people buying
carbon-based you know fossil fuels
for other purposes basically
with cheap energy availability people
still want to grow and expand and use
more energy so if you were to replace
the entire us grid with nuclear power
that's great we would reduce our carbon
footprint and then everyone would be
like awesome now the energy is so cheap
i can buy more gas to do these things
so so
so i'm with you on the the what we
should have been doing for a long time
now and haven't been
is working on
carbon capture
ways to do that that that's really the
only
sensible kind of thing and i go back to
my my first job in government
in the 70s in in the
department of energy a summer intern
right and i was like trying to figure
out
how to reduce our oil import dependence
on the middle east because it was
causing wars and
embargoes and poverty and all that kind
of stuff like that
never ever did i imagine in the 1970s
could this country ever
become energy independent
but we did that during the trump
administration because of a change in
technology fracking and so
this is how i think we're going to get
out of the the climate change box if you
believe you're we're in one it's that
carbon capture it has to be the only
sensible way to do that otherwise you're
going to force americans to save
you know your
family saves a pound of carbon and
meanwhile the chinese create two two
pounds for every pound we save and they
wind up they wind up being
the leaders of the world uh in the
prosperous country and we can't we can't
have that for a lot of reasons i want to
jump to this next story from the daily
mail
mississippi's largest city runs out of
water indefinitely over 180 000 people
are left without drinking water and
can't flush their toilets or take
showers what after floods made jackson's
water treatment plant fail
jackson mississippi rented a water
indefinitely leaving more than 180 000
residents of that water governor tate
reeves announced on monday the city's
failing water system was completely down
due to years of poor infrastructure
mayor chokwe antar lumumba
said the recent mississippi flood
strained the city's water plan water
plan so i i just want to tell you this
you know when i tell people the
education you're going to need right now
is how to survive i hope the people of
jackson know how to pull water from the
air solar powered water condensation
well i mean you don't really need to do
that you can just put a piece of plastic
at an angle and then bend the bottom so
you can humidity out of the air or you
can dig tunnels underground where the
wind goes underground and then condenses
and then creates like a puddle of water
underground yeah i mean like the basic
thing is you dig a hole you put a cup in
it you put plastic wrap and then the
condensation trickles down but they have
these big things you can buy they're
just they're just plastic sheets that go
roll down into tubes you put it up and
in the morning all of the humidity
condenses and then goes down you get
some water but uh anyway look i don't
think that's going to be practical for a
city of 180 000 people but when you see
stuff like this there should be a cold
splash of water in the face
that uh
yo
we don't live in in elysium we don't
live in a world of infinite resources we
live in a bubble protected by people
with guns and machines that secure
resources easily for us the reality of
the world at any moment this could be
gone and i've talked about this because
i remember like 10 years ago in ohio i
don't remember how long how long ago was
there was an algebra bloom
and all of the water became toxic
because of the algae and there was no
water for 40 miles it was i can't
remember what city it was was cincinnati
or something i think so i don't know and
so people were driving out buying
bottled water and then it was all
disappearing there was nothing
because you couldn't get your water
source went dirty there you know i i see
so many people who just live
assuming everything's always going to be
fine there's always water there's always
food i got nothing to worry about then
one day there's going to be a flood
they're going to have no water no food
and they're going to scream save me and
no one's going to be there to hear it
that's the reality of what's going on
right now man
and by the way how much was it that we
just sent to ukraine oh they're trying
to do a billionaire how much how much
could that have been used to
do the infrastructure and uh injection
for a little water well desalination
yeah i mean if we i do
like i don't if you remember flint flint
michigan when when they lost their water
source it took years
years
years for that thing to recover and it
left a lot of
a lot of kids damaged it took months to
get billions to ukraine you know so that
that's good news i guess
we can snap our fingers and send money
to a foreign country that's not us put
our troops on their border pull our
border patrol and send them to poland
but uh fixed pipes in flint i don't know
about that it's it's frightening how
particularly in this this age we're in
in the biden stagflation economy
how many people in this country live
paycheck to paycheck to paycheck i mean
it's
it it with the turn a quick turn of the
screw here
um
there's going to be
even more pain that we're already
suffering i mean there's a lot of people
now
who can't pay their mortgages who can't
pay their rent
and that message i somehow
you don't read much about that in new
york times or see it on cnn or something
i wonder why i'm really concerned with
the student loan stuff because of this
because like if someone's struggling to
pay their mortgage and then they find
out that they got ten thousand dollars
siphoned away from them to pay for some
college guy that there's going to be a
class hatred just like soviet union man
i do not like where this is a mortgage
mortgage strike like in china
yeah when was that yeah right now oh
yeah yeah yeah i mean yeah and that
stuff can spread like uh
as they say in china prairie fire that
scares the hell out of the chinese
communist party when people start
resisting like that yup
but you need more i suppose
and they suppress the information there
but uh yeah china's on the verge of
collapse
i don't know man
i kind of think that uh
people aren't really paying attention to
the supply crisis that's been happening
here in the u.s so i'm not surprised to
see a story about a city running out of
water
people so we we're having construction
done on the new headquarters and it's
been stalled it's been a year now i'm
glad you raised that because the last
time i was here was about a year we
talked about okay this is going to be
really cool going to your new
studio and just saying the other thing
it's like brian gets me in the car he's
like where are we going oh same old
place what's going on
uh it's hard to get materials nobody's
working that's right my joke is the
rapture happened the it's the only way
to explain it airlines are shutting down
there's no employees i went through out
there are fewer people there are fewer
people everywhere i went to a diner
saturday at noon and they were like
we're closed due to short staff i'm like
where are the people at how are like
people gotta eat right people gotta pay
rent what's going on where are they so
jokingly i'm like they must have they
must have gotten raptured and we just
don't know or something but they're gone
and so uh we're trying to get this
building put up
and they put they they're a year behind
a year behind it's we're we're a year
behind what's your finished date now
with with there's none it's stalled now
it's dead it's the project's stalled and
this is and it's because they're like
the materials are unavailable
people people don't see this stuff
because
you know
look
most people aren't dealing with ordering
steel for instance or putting up a
building so they don't see that behind
the scenes the core materials that we
need did you know that one of the
largest aluminum plants in this country
shut down did you you remember that
story honestly i do remember that was it
20 of us aluminum production wow they
said they couldn't afford the
electricity anymore whoa so and i'm like
we're saving our aluminum cans and you
think yeah there's no reason why they
can't afford the electricity anymore
because the price of aluminum
has been driven down by subsidized
chinese aluminum that's like one of the
things that i fought in the white house
you know we put in place
uh steel and aluminum tariffs to provide
a defense against that kind of stuff and
sure so here's what we do we take the we
take our cans yeah and we we're smelting
them down to ingots we have aluminum
someone's apparently done that like i
found a box with with aluminum we are
saving the cans probably recycle or
something but uh somebody actually it
might be chris
he's melting him down in ingots
i mean we you know quite hey look i know
there's a supply chain crisis but it's
actually ground to a halt your new
experience so uh
it was supposed to be done last year
yeah like a year ago and then they were
like it's delayed we have to wait we
have to wait and then finally in the
spring they're like we're gonna lay the
concrete then they're like as now the
concrete foundation's up we should be
able to get the steel and get the
building done
now it's august the uh eighty percent of
the framing is done and they stopped and
left and they're like we don't have the
supplies so now it's just sitting there
stalled again
it's absolutely insane and i'm hearing
this for tom from tons of people saying
that there's a bunch of materials
they're unable to get right now and they
have to wait let me refer you to carbon
dioxide and the graphene that we could
make out of it this i know i'm not like
focused on the step right in front of me
i'm kind of focused on the next third
step fifth and seventh after that but
i'm like down to work with anybody in
the in the government i don't know if
the government's the right place to go
with this i imagine american industry
but it was always like carnegie was a
private sector guy he didn't build this
the americans didn't build the steel
industry well and america did carnegie
what's it william carnegie says
um what do you think should i should i
so let's i mean let's let's uh let's
take it to the reality again what i did
in the trump administration i think
everything you're saying
underscores the need
to
produce domestically okay it's not just
to have the steel
factories here themselves but to have
the supply chains that go with it and we
got hooked starting back
1960s on these these globalized supply
chains because it was cheaper
yeah that's the idea and no one ever
factored in the appropriate
geopolitical risk of being being
dependent on a china or russia for
energy or whatever
and it was all about um
also cheap labor so that's why
everything got out there
and i you know i spent four years in the
white house trying to buy american thing
trying to make sure
i mean you take like one of the one of
the the achievements i think we had was
i did a buy american executive order
um on on essential pharmaceuticals okay
and there's there's three
there's three components to that you've
got the the finished
dosage product itself right and then
you've got the intermediate chemicals
you need to make it and then you got raw
materials and the problem we have
is that those first two stages are
completely almost all
offshore
okay
as well as a good part of the finished
dosage stuff so bringing that back
i'm very difficult and the biggest
biggest uh
two
forces i had to fight
were
the big pharma folks you know they'd
come in their freaking gucci shoes and
into the uh old
eisenhower executive building we sit
around a table and say hey we got to do
this like this was like
early pandemic it's like we can't we
can't be dependent on these people and
they say no no no impossible to do that
they would find it but then the fda
would fight it
as well because the fda
is the servant a big pharma like those
folks go through revolving doors they
get jobs there they got stocks this any
other thing
but the point is that
if we
source
our production as well as our supply
chains
then
we won't be having the problems we're
having and and there's no
reason on god's good earth why we should
be short on aluminum and steel i mean we
got everything we need
in minnesota where do people at yeah
well the rapture happens well don't
expect
that's an interesting kind of issue
in it of itself because um
you know there's there's topics we
probably don't want to go here but it's
like there's reasons why people are out
of the workforce
who got pushed out of the workforce
and
this is a a political
tragedy it's not an economic tragedy it
starts with your downstream politics
here
you know politics maybe are downstream
to economics but what you're saying
about the
medical production or biomedical
production i mean the biden
administration just signed this 11
million deal to bring the is it the last
step of manufacturing the monkey pox
vaccine to the us from a danish
manufacturer they're
manufacturing i believe in michigan so
in some ways they are doing what you're
saying just only when forced to in
complete crisis
well
yeah
there's there's there's about 400
essential medicines that that we need in
our in our cabinet
and um you know certainly okay great you
got the monkey pox done but but what
have you done lately for
for all of the
um
advanced pharmaceutical ingredients the
api and the raw materials you need
for insulin for example or whatever
whatever it is and i'm i'm just telling
you that
that for a lot of reasons that stuff's
the the most basic stuff's in india and
china because they don't have any
environmental rules and that's kind of
nasty
nasty do and i was able to there's a
company called flow it's p-h-l-o-w
i was able to get
get
some some grant money for them
and they had a process where they did
all three stages under one building so
you were able to get economies of scale
and scope across that and those are the
kinds of things i mean we've never
we can't compete as a manufacturing
country
worker for worker what we have to do is
we gotta we gotta produce
um more efficiently by having the best
and smartest machines wedded to the best
and smartest labor
and that's what our focus is all right
we're gonna go to super chats if you
haven't already would you kindly smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
head over to timcast.com we're gonna
have a members only show coming up at
about 11 p.m so you don't want to miss
that plus check out the new cast castle
episode marjorie taylor green is a
special guest and
she is the mtg slayer
it's really funny you wanna check it out
all right let's read what we got here
all right
raymond g stanley jr says well done fake
woke is moving up them charts you see
isn't that amazing fake woke number
three and that's tom mcdonald if if i
think you'd need like 50 000 people
if they bought fake woke i think he'd be
like billboard hot 100 or something
is it is that is that impossible to do
50 000 people just to spend a buck to
help support you know culture and stuff
like that it's possible and that's 50
that would end up being probably like 35
40 grand in time mcdonald's pocket too
that's the crazy thing it's like if
everybody pitched in a dollar imagine
what you could accomplish
like people would just own the culture
well you always say like stop giving
money to people who hate you and i think
people think about it when they're
buying products or shopping at
restaurants but like shopping
eating out but when you are buying music
or stream music you are doing the exact
same thing you have the ability to
influence well it's all you know look
jeremy boring uh daley wire said stop
giving money to people who hate you give
it to me instead i'll put it this way
start giving money to people you like
yeah or to people who are making things
you like yeah you know whoever that may
be
all right smokey joe says never
underestimate establishment gop's
ability to waste opportunity if they eke
out their win it won't be celebration
but an enormous wash of relief
false god dark soul says pop culture
crisis is greater than irl
uh well uh well actually pop culture
crisis um we had a day today it was very
well thirteen hundred dollars something
like that in super chats yeah we had 13
crisis parties the christ party meter
goes off every time we reach a hundred
dollars in super chats uh someone
actually super chatted that in and our
response was we'll say it to tim on irl
tonight so well there you go
there you go uh but yeah you guys should
check that out at three o'clock right
now in super chat's pop culture crisis
for the day is oh sorry nope nope that's
it someone super chatted us right now
and now we're officially beating pop
culture christmas there's a nice try
brett and mary
you guys don't have the lights and the
money guns like it's a different
experience here yeah so if those aren't
familiar pop culture crisis is a pop
culture show that we launched and it's
more
fun pop culture not political and then
whenever a hundred dollars in super
chats comes in money guns start firing
guns into the air and the lights go off
anytime you super chat the money guns go
up but yeah it's a hundred we get like a
lot of you have to try and talk through
while like these lights are flashing
and you're like i'm making an
interesting point i swear man ian said
it what the money got in his coffee yeah
one time yeah that happened to me too
there you go
i like pick up my coffee and like hold
it when they're going off gotta protect
it all right ry lyon says chat last
night said tired of diversity
inclusivity and equity training at uh at
job i was too made policies
discriminated against whites and men
found new job and filed complaint you
can't do
i'll just say this ladies and gentlemen
if you work for a company and they make
you watch a video
that discriminates on the basis of race
complain and file file a complaint and
see see how fast they change their
policies see this is the issue
i don't care about the race of the
individual you can't discriminate on the
basis of race these die trainings are
are coming out being like white
privilege or whatever okay well that's
still against the law you need to only
be like hey they were saying a bunch of
racist things in that video and then
they're gonna be like uh what here's
what i say you file a complaint and you
say my boss made us watch a racist video
what were they saying in that video i
refuse to repeat the racist things they
said you're not going to make me say it
you like that's it they made us watch a
video where a bunch of racist things
were happening where people were saying
racist things to people where people
were encouraging racism and it's like
what specifically was it you're not
going to get me to repeat the racisms
sorry but they'll they'll fold not
everybody you know i've talked about
this before some companies will be like
screw you because they're in a cult you
know what i mean
some people might panic and back oh no
we're gonna get sued if we do this again
all right george m says loved loved your
no bs attitude mr navarro a bit of a fan
i have worked in manufacturing my whole
life and now own my own automation
business how could we talk about rapid
made in america resurgence strategy
yeah that's it that's
that's a hits the nail on the head these
are the kind of advanced manufacturing
techniques that we could have been
nurturing there was a
a key point
during the pandemic
when
we were trying to
work with the democrats
on a stimulus bill which at the time was
was was appropriate given the mess
we were in and the battle was really
over how you'd spend the money
and in the trump side of the fence
what we wanted to do was was use a bunch
of that money
to onshore
manufacturing and build manufacturing
under the assumption that if you were
going to stimulate
the economy and create rising real wages
and prosperity the best way to do that
would be to have jobs here and part of
the money that would have been spent
would be on these advanced manufacturing
techniques so you could stay ahead of
the sweatshops and pollution havens
of asia so good for uh super chat man
there all right alex alcala says rapture
probably did happen i don't see sheamus
anymore is that what that was
i went out i went out one day and i saw
a naked sheamus being pulled up into the
sky through a sunbeam and i just i
assumed he was going to the stores i
thought he was flying
how he gets around yeah he's i thought
it was a normal pack or something
haven't seen him since yeah he's gone
that makes sense
yeah and also he didn't put out a
cartoon for a while oh my gosh
that's just because he's lazy
just kidding i'm just kidding sheamus
oh he's gonna he's he's sitting in a
lounge chair right now in like a
bathrobe and he's like curling his
fingers like
claire he always used to steal my desk
when he was here i would say good
riddance
jaden giroux says longtime listener
first time super chatter wanted to say
that only ever wanted is my favorite new
song of 2022. can't wait to see what
else you guys release keep up the good
work
yeah i think the next song is like in
one month
our plan is gonna it's gonna so what we
got to figure it out because there's
only so much we can do but we might be
putting out like a piano light soft you
know version of it
we'll see violin or something because uh
uh and then i think for a month from
then the next song uh the next official
song is we we want to get out a new song
every four weeks and definitely a new
song every single month forever moving
forward
literally forever
uh be it from me or you know anybody
else that we end up signing and things
like that but it means we need to expand
the operation it means we need to
generate revenue from the operation and
we're working with some uh
some some rat dudes we'll see you know i
don't want to say too much but uh
there's a lot of interest i'll put it
this way after the success of this song
we put out the interest is through the
roof and we've got people reaching out
to us they want to work with us and
expand the operation because uh
yeah a lot of views a lot of a lot of
hits to that song only ever wanted click
the link below if you don't if you want
to buy it appreciate the support but
because of all your support now we've
got people are like dude let's let's
make more let's work together and we've
got some interest that's going to help
kick things up to the next level
waffle sensei says ian is out here doing
the lord's work trying to spread the
word about graphene and save the world
and my guy tim here dressed in black
block trying to shut him up shaking my
head
without resistance you will fail
yeah everybody needs a little conflict
right raymond g stanley jr says save the
ian save the world
david back says never change ian never
change that's an inevitable change
all right we'll grab some more super
chats
stan says biden planning a thursday
primetime live message think he will
announce or address any trump charges
no but is lauren in town then we should
we should we should hit up lauren
southern and tell her she has to be in
town to do another
biden speech night drunk obviously funny
that was hilarious the last thing you
heard about this no no no what happened
we uh the last time biden did uh you say
to the union i think we had a drinking
party and like then we had we played
bingo
every time biden would do a predictable
thing you'd mark it off and then see who
won
did you watch that his state of state of
the union it was like a campaign speech
they called it a state of the union but
he just talked about what he was going
to do i i rarely watch things in real
time i'm an asynchronous kind of guy so
i'll catch that stuff later
i i just i haven't i have a really
difficult time
even watching joe biden i remember
during the campaign
it was very clear to me and i said this
repeatedly publicly that
this man was was mentally diminished
that he would not serve out as full term
and that we were going to hand over the
country to somebody
who was both incompetent and corrupt and
i mean
as old as he
looked and acted on inauguration day i
mean that man is he's approaching
ghoul-like ghost-like
uh i mean it's just it's just weird i
mean he's he's aging faster
than any than they can personally
i mean it's just
scary and yeah man yeah i mean we might
wind up with kamala
as president god help us uh you get what
you ask for all right aidan says rip
mikhail gorbachev that's right he died
he was the uh the worst leader in soviet
history yes yes the one that oversaw the
demise of the soviet union but by us
from our perspective the best the best
is great thank you
yeah apparently he was really upset that
putin was destroying his legacy that's
what i saw in a report and i'm like oh
okay
all right
w falcon says hey tim when are we going
to get the shane cashman your honesty is
appreciated but your reality is
disgusting coffee mug oh is that one of
his quotes that's fantastic that's great
um yeah we should make that now well you
know what we we need to expand a lot so
we really need to just grow
hire more people but there's only so
many people we can hire because we're
kind of at our limit
and uh so we need more people to sign up
and watch inverted world more people to
watch cass castle and we're offering
these things trying to get more and more
people we're spending a lot of money in
marketing and it is what it is it's slow
growth but pop culture crisis is
starting to take off getting a lot of
new subscribers every day 1300 in super
chats in one day i failed to mention
that brett and i have a wager where if
you get 15 super chat or crisis parties
in one episode he'll bleach his hair no
mary will bleach it for him mary is his
co-host he's got gorgeous blonde hair uh
just in case you guys needed a reason to
tune in tomorrow at 3 p.m i definitely
think you should go check out pop
culture crisis
well i said 10 crisis batteries and he
said no 15. which i thought was real
it's gonna happen yeah of course well as
we got closer today we like suddenly
like suddenly hit 10 and we could see
brett eyes like shifting
and he was like okay so let's do outros
let's wrap this show up about how it
works
it's gonna be like 14.99 he's gonna go
show's over click
and then someone's gonna send him the
dollar before the show can he get 30
seconds but i have to watch the first
fast and the furious because we hit 10
uh crystals oh really yeah which i've
never seen and i'm opposed to generally
why
why are there 10 fast and furious movies
don't you think that's too many are
there eleven they're working on their
tenth i don't know well it's f9 plus
hobbs and shaw i guess no
the the ffcu is the is the greatest
cinematic universe
you should come on pop culture crisis in
different oh dude
in the latest in the latest fast and
furious
they went to outer space oh like that's
stupid that was amazing no i want to
happen
what i want to happen
is i want vin diesel and his crew to be
like yo we got another driving mission
it's at this nuclear power plant top
secret job and then they like go in but
then there's an explosion they get
blasted with radiation and they all get
super powers and then like
like vin diesel gets super speed and
then you know ludicrous becomes like he
gets like tech nut tech no powers where
the techno kinesis he can control
machines
and then they're like flying around but
then like there's because they already
they already have superpowers in it in
hobbs and shaw idris elba was a super
soldier with like nanotech modifications
like we're already here dude i want
superhero vin diesel oh no
do you have an opinion on fast and
furious peter navarro i do not
haven't watched any
any of the i've heard they they keep
getting made because they always make
money and i can understand that you went
to outer space that is stupid no it's
not it is the greatest thing ever no
wasn't there one of their stars though
that tragically died yeah yeah paul
walker right yeah he was the original
yes yes
that i did
with some tragedy yes yeah yes they
should do it on mine maybe you should
watch fast and furious with me because i
don't know that i i'll i'll keep my word
but
you know i'm i'm more of a kind of a
slow and mellow kind of guy these days
you know what i mean
target
here's here's a question for peter
peter provenzano says what have you
trump and bannon learned about your bad
personnel decisions millie esper bolton
etc and how will it be fixed in the next
administration
well uh in the taking back trump's
america book i do offer the dream
cabinet
as well as the dream staffing of the
white house and as far as i can see
um if they put somebody like one of my
favorites back from the trump days this
guy named johnny mcatee i met him during
the campaign
he was originally one of the two body
men for the boss you know we'd fly out
on uh
we called it trump force one right which
was the
the the trump plane where he'd go
campaign and stuff like that johnny um
uh
joined the administration he got treated
really badly by chief of staff kelly but
he came back at the end to run the
personnel decision all you need is the
mcat filter on there um to get the right
people in
uh and
we got to get trump back in but we also
got to get the right people and to run
run around the world here that's the
most important thing is you know and
also firing all the wrong people all the
schedule left stuff right yes yes yes i
mean look uh the thing about the thing
about a second trump term
is that the boss knows how to do this
now from day one
and he's got people who know
how to do it and um
we know what to do we know what to do on
the economy certainly what do you think
about you got ben shapiro ann coulter
laura uh laura ingram even alex jones
saying trump's not the right path
forward many of them saying ron desantis
well
keep in mind that my
bailiwick is
fair trade making sure that traders
don't cheat
and american manufacturing and
i don't know
that ron desantis has ever said a word
about
cracking down on chinese economic
aggression and imposing tariffs it's not
clear to me that he knows anything
about that issue but that's going to be
the key to getting back our economy and
yeah look i know the boss
i love the guy i know he knows what to
do and so i'm a trump guy
yeah all right
this is a good one mahil says in my
experience boxes are usually empty or
maybe with a little cheese stuck to the
top and one time pepperoni what a day
that was all right who knows the
reference
oh the fbi rated 11 pizza boxes from
trump's house and that's no no one knows
the reference
no i don't know ah that's too bad
zoidberg feature
yep you all you all get three demerits
stephen hardman says i'd like to know
this gentleman's opinion on nuclear
power its potential role in aiding in
what seems to be a global energy crisis
and should we consider domestic
production of uranium as an area of
national importance and security
first book i ever wrote in 1984 the
dimming of america the central
thesis of that book is that
bad regulation around the country was
suppressing the development
of colon nuclear power plants and that
would lead
to electricity shortages in 2000
and i was in california when that and
enron hit
the
the trick with nuclear power and it's a
big trick is to figure out how to build
themselves safely but again apropos talk
with ian about technology i mean there's
there's smaller
safer
modular kind of systems that can be
built standardized
and um they they have a place
[Music]
in our in our grid i mean this whole
electric vehicle thing and the biden
administration keeps forgetting that in
order for an electric vehicle to run
they need electricity
right yep
have you seen nuclear diamond batteries
they're recovering spent nuclear fuel
like nuclear waste and then they're
putting it inside of diamond and it's
creating a low charge for like you get
like 10 000 years of electrical charges
by the way i buried the lead about
desantis in the in the trading back
trump's america book i recommend
desantis as the vp choice
right away if they can seal that deal
like now
that'll clear the field yeah and
santa should do that
because then he'd be in the white house
for 12 years i agree i agree i think it
it's it you know we had i think with
santorum who was on and said 12 years of
a republican presidency is
wishful thinking but i still think it's
probably the right approach desantis was
not in the white house he just was he
was in congress before the governor's
[ __ ]
donald trump
went through this on the first congress
desantis yeah yeah yeah right he was
right pretty sure i don't know look that
out he wasn't i don't think he was i
don't remember him being kind of like he
might have been stated
oh is that what it was in the state
house he kind of came over
he came out of nowhere
trump saved him uh
i don't know if he saved him but the
trump endorsement kind of propelled him
in in what was a highly competitive race
at the time
and look he acquitted himself very very
well
on something that he and i totally agree
on which was that you know the the the
follies of fouchy and everything fouchy
did he did the opposite of
and then right on
you know they they locked down for a
little while but things got better i
think i think it's a good move let's
read some more we got xrunner who says
my plumber friend laughs get a degree or
you will be a burger flipper he gets
served at starbucks by masters holders
me
that's true it's like there's a meme
where it's uh it's a woman holding a
book and it's like 120 000 in student
loans no job in debt wants you to pay
for it and then it's like a guy working
on a telephone pole and it's like 100
hundred thousand dollar dollars a year
union job no debt
like it's not going to yeah it's not
gonna yeah exactly
shuts off the electricity of the yeah
eleventh hour studio says huge thanks to
tim cast and the thousands who viewed my
cover of will of the people uploaded a
much higher quality re-record and a
cover of only ever wanted on the way
great show tonight as always
uh right on men
so uh will of the people is the first
song we put out and i was actually
really bummed when going through the
data it would have been it would have
hit the charts because we didn't know
what we were doing we just uploaded the
song we were like hey look we did a song
and it's actually doing really really
well in the past like two months it's
gotten like hundreds of thousands of
hits on spotify which i didn't even
realize just started doing really well
and then it's funny to see all these
lefties saying that they liked the song
and then they realized it was from me
and they're like oh no oh no
paul renfer says when do we get a song
where tim sings it in that homeless
voice
i mean maybe on chicken city or
something great chicken city the album
chicken city we have a chicken city
theme song we are we already demo
tracked it too
it's going to be great
yeah chicken city man
all right jeffrey dubois says hey guys
i'm a big fan tim can you set up a
process for us to donate money to
specific projects we want like the
website being developed or the app or
some other project in the works well i
mean that's fantastic if if you sign up
to become a member at timcast.com
there's a bunch of different tiers it's
like 10 bucks to be a member and then
the other tiers are basically like if
you give 25 bucks you're basically
giving a 15 donation on top of the 10
price so uh we we've yeah i'll leave it
at that you can choose to give more as
for like the app and the website being
developed it's just
labor you know like we we have the
resources to fund it we don't have the
people and finding them is difficult
it's not easy
yeah the rapture happened like where is
everybody so we have and it's not just
that but like
look hiring is a minefield someone walks
up to your door or you know emails you
and they're like i'll take a job and
you've got to figure out if they're
capable of doing it and it's hard
so you know
it's difficult man
let's grab some more super chats
all right dave wiggins says love that
you were able to get navarro on here
amazing to see the context and
personality of an individual especially
after seeing the insanity we live in
very powerful to see these individuals
as regular people hoping for the best
that's right absolutely
mavis says loan forgiveness is all fun
and games until states like new york's
new york tax it as income
and they will why wouldn't they
you think the government's going to give
you 10 grand and the state's going to be
like oh
we're not interested in that 10 grand of
your own tax money and then they're
going to tax you on it can you imagine
that that's right i stand by biden just
did this to be able to say i am the
student loan forgiveness president well
he student loan accelerated repayment
program president is what he's doing
he's trying to make us pay back our own
loans fast
maybe service guarantees citizenship man
nick says tom mcdonald is great but
don't sleep on chris webby you'll love
his raw thoughts v if you like tom right
on okay
only ever wanted said
in the end what separates a man from a
slave money power no a man chooses a
slave obeys andrew ryan bioshock
what a great game
all right
david scott says you got to get tony
heller on the show who's that
i don't know that
no tony heller
marion holtzman says you live in a blue
state no problem here in tennessee to
get anything done i've been constructing
for three years no problem no we're in
west virginia
west virginia is maga country baby
but uh there's like there's like a big
thing happening because there's like a
child there's an all ages drag show
happening in martinsburg and also in
like everybody's starting to like lose
their minds i guess so like
it's all being shared on the local
forums and they're like why
i'm like i'm kind of worried like why
would you put on a drag show all ages in
maga country you know
martinsburg like west virginia is really
interesting because they get a flow of
people from dc and northern virginia
coming no i get it but it's still maga
country i think that they don't think it
is because they're like oh it's sort of
a city and so we we occupy here like
they think they're being um
provocative enough where they'll only
attract like-minded people and i just i
think it's not well thought out
yeah man i was we were looking at
setting up an operation in martinsburg
but i'm gonna steer clear of that stuff
and it's not just about the drag show
for for kids it's that there was a diner
that was closed at noon on a saturday
and i'm just like it's a bad place to
buy property oh you know
they they their people there think that
it's become it's coming up it's the city
in west virginia and i feel bad because
i'd love to see west virginia thrive but
not if that's the kind of thriving that
comes to town when you start building it
up you know what i mean so i'm kind of
like nah
go somewhere else man yeah
yeah maybe maybe move further you know
west into west virginia
all right we'll grab a couple more here
10 bucks too says fast and furious 23
revengeance the crew goes on the
ultimate heist they steal time by racing
inside the large hadron collider they
gotta steal the original copy of fast
and the furious they go back in time
if there are 20 fast and furious i will
be real mad i will be quite furious
indeed
that's too many you might love it by
then no i don't think i will i mean i
want to stay open-minded you might be
resigning future is being written all
right everybody if you haven't already
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.com and become a member to help
support our work we're gonna have a
members only show coming up in just a
little bit and click the link in the
description below it'll bring you over
to band camp where it's very very easy
to just click buy the song for 69 cents
if you want to support only ever wanted
if you guys buy enough we might actually
chart which would be really cool
otherwise buy the sony check it out or
it's available on all streaming
platforms if you want to check it out
there and we're gonna be releasing a lot
more the goal with this is just to make
culture and uh look i would have been
satisfied if the song came out and had
like you know 50 to 100k hits and we
were like you know that's all it is
instead it's got like a million plus you
know combined on all these other
platforms and it's kind of crazy and uh
you know it is what it is really do
appreciate all the support
uh you can follow the show at tim castro
you can follow me at tim cast peter do
you want to shout anything out
uh yeah as long as we're pushing stuff
uh let's get me to amazon number one
taking back trump's america and by the
way this book doubles as my legal
defense fund so help your brother out
baby taking him back
available on amazon today it's the key
to getting back the house of
representatives in the november election
and the white house
in 2024 when were you on list
about a year ago when the earlier book
this is this is a planned uh second book
of the three memoirs from my white house
years but i decided
uh given the biden fiasco to make sure
that this was prospective as a way of of
of showing how what we did the first
term
would help us
move forward and get back to white house
again uh in 2025. right on man that's
right thanks for coming you got it you
my charge my book charts hey so let's
get it
it's all good but the problem is if we
get money we still can't build anything
because there's no supply chain well but
i'm working on that too
all right all right hey i might know
where we can find some graphene graphene
yes the air yeah oh you're right
i'm hannah claremlow i want to say happy
birthday to my older brother he's
excellent and i'm a huge fan uh you can
find me on timcast.com you can click on
the read tabs you work for me and the
rest of our news team you can also find
me on instagram hannah claire.b thanks
so much hey guys follow me ian crossland
on the internet anywhere any social
media wherever you want to and peter
always a pleasure my man my brother
looking good graphene baby all the way
myself i actually knew about that guy's
stepson is a graphene freak awesome you
must listen to ian there's more to it
it's a theme structure there's like
borophene as well the boron and that's
the same he's putting he's building an
internet with photons
okay oh yeah
well the idea is you can you can you can
do you can transmit for internet
purposes using photons
light fidelity yes cool yeah that's your
name he introduced me and my stepson he
introduced me to graphene oh it's
beautiful physics physics guy yes future
all right thank you guys all very much
for tuning in this casual tuesday i am
on pop culture crisis tomorrow three to
five p.m eastern standard time let's see
if we can get brett to dye his hair or
to bleach it right oh my gosh so
exciting i'd love to see this you know
you want to see an eminem brett you do
oh yeah just search
search pop culture crisis on youtube
subscribe it is a similar format show to
this but it's actually the more fun
version like we laugh sometimes but pop
culture crisis is like money guns firing
off while people are talking landing in
coffee and talking about games tv shows
movies so yes it was meant to be more
entertainment where we're very serious
and screaming like the end isn't here
alex jones comes on he's banging the
table about as a gorilla and you know
actually that's pretty fun that was
pretty fun too yes it is very fun it's a
totally different vibe you guys should
check it out like i always say politics
is downstream of culture keep up with
the culture on pop culture crisis you
guys can follow me on twitterminds.com
at sourpatchlids as well as
southpatulitz.me we will see you all at
timcast.com we'll be hanging out with
peter for a special uncensored uh
segment it comes comes up at about 11
p.m we'll see y'all then thanks for
hanging out
you